[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablarte salud por
ello saludo en el estudio a mi compañera
mar Romero salamar bienvenida Buenos
días Andrés mar vamos a hablar de
genética y de un reciente avance que ha
vivido el mundo científico esta semana
cuéntenos sí concretamente el miércoles
se publicó el nuevo pangenoma humano de
referencia no sé si cómo te quedas con
esto no no tengo ni idea Bueno vamos a
explicar no pasa nada no vamos a empezar
por el principio como siempre Andrés un
genomas la secuencia total de un ADN en
este caso del ADN de los humanos y hasta
ahora solo existía un solo genoma de
referencia una secuencia de ADN que se
usaba para toda investigación científica
toda investigación genética se empezó a
secuenciar hace 20 años y solo se
completó al 100% hacia el año pasado que
de hecho dábamos la noticia también
alrededor de estas fechas cuál era su
principal crítica que este genoma humano
que se usaba como referencia para toda
investigación genética estaba hecha
solamente en base a 20 personas de las
cuales el 87% eran de ascendencia
europea eran personas blancas un 10% de
las tendencias asiática y solo un 2% de
ascendencia africana un 1% hispánica no
Además un dato nuevo también es que de
toda esta secuencia del genoma humano el
70% provenía solo de una persona que era
precisamente una persona Blanca por lo
tanto se criticaba que no refleja la
diversidad de la humanidad y que sesga
por lo tanto la investigación científica
que se desprende de ese genoma ahora con
estas nuevas investigaciones la
información sobre el genoma humano es
mucho más completa muéstranos Exacto
esto que decíamos es hasta fecha de hoy
porque hay un trabajo que ha hecho el
consorcio de referencia del pangema
humano que forma parte de los institutos
nacionales de salud de Estados Unidos y
han secuenciado el genoma de 47 personas
de orígenes muy diversos la mitad de
ellos por ejemplo son de origen africano
También incluye 16 personas del
continente americano como curiosidad son
cuatro personas peruanas de Lima cuatro
colombianos de Medellín y ocho
puertorriqueños solo unos europeos
porque ya sabemos que ya está sobre
representada no esa muestra en la
secuencia económica y el primer borrador
de todos estos genomas se publicó en la
revista nature el miércoles pasado
Entonces hasta ahora digamos que
teníamos una secuencia genómica lineal
no una sola línea que era la referencia
sin embargo ahora como que vemos aquí
nos publicaban un ejemplo tenemos algo
que se parece más Incluso como unas
líneas de metro un mapa de líneas de
metro en el que vemos que la secuencia
no solo va en una dirección sino que
puede tomar distintos caminos A qué nos
referimos con esto Pues que los genomas
de las personas son distintos en el 99%
somos iguales pero hay 1% un 1% que es
diferente y que aquí donde vemos que
pone inserción duplicación que hay una
letra arriba que es distinta la de abajo
son estas variantes se llaman variantes
estructurales que pueden ser distintas Y
que ahora a partir de ahora sabremos que
pues tenemos esta referencia también y
se pueden comparar con estos caminos que
cogen No eso qué significa también pues
bueno por supuesto mayor precisión un
conocimiento más complejo Que absorbe
toda esta complejidad del ADN que nos
hace humanos ahora cuáles los mayores
aportes los aportes específicos de esta
nueva investigación pues para
explicártelo bien Vamos a y para
explicarlo bien a los televidentes vamos
a empezar también muy por el principio
no el ADN es como un manual de
instrucciones que determina como nos
vemos como somos y cómo funciona nuestro
cuerpo y está compuesto por algo que
llamamos bases que son unos compuestos
químicos y hay cuatro compuestos
químicos distintos se llaman tiene bueno
se representan con unas letras la letra
atg y C y el ADN digamos es letra tras
letra tras letra tras letra hasta llegar
a un total de aproximadamente 3.055
millones de letras es decir si
tuviéramos que leerlas todas no
terminaríamos hoy Andrés entonces un
grupo de estas bases conforma un gen
pueden ser genes cortos es decir que
tengan un fenus centenares de bases o
pueden ser genes largos que tengan hasta
10.000 bases por poner un ejemplo Y
estos genes determinan estas cualidades
o funciones de nuestro cuerpo Entonces
esta nueva investigación gracias a ver
secuenciado estos 47 genomas más añade
119 millones de bases es un aporte
sustancial encuentran más de mil
duplicaciones de genes de zonas en el
genoma donde se duplican secuencias
genéticas y también duplica es decir
aumentan más de un 100% las variantes
estructurales esas partes distintas que
veíamos en ese mapa antes que se conocen
No donde un trozo de secuencia cambia de
lugar se repite duplica se elimina
etcétera bueno Y finalmente vamos a
aterrizar este tema un poco más Qué
aplicaciones tiene este hallazgo en la
salud exactamente Andrés Pues
básicamente uno de los principales
autores del estudio lo explica de la de
las distintas de esta forma no estas
duplicaciones estas variantes
estructurales eran partes del genoma que
antes estaban inaccesibles Y que ahora
no lo son las podemos ver las conocemos
y esto puede acelerar la investigación
clínica al mejorar la comprensión
nuestra comprensión del vínculo entre
estas genes entre la genética y las
enfermedades de hecho en su publicación
en nature hacían un ejemplo bastante
curioso Y es que se referían que estos
nuevos datos pueden el antídoto a una
cosa que se llama el efecto farola que
hace referencia a un chiste de un señor
borracho que pierde sus llaves en el
parque y solo las Busca en cambio
alrededor de la luz de una sola farola
en la noche y cuando le preguntan por
qué estás buscando solo aquí si las
perdiste en otro lugar es porque no ve
más allá entonces qué decíamos hasta
ahora no pues la investigación genética
se ha centrado al final en la única zona
que veíamos lo único que iluminaba este
genoma de referencia no dentro de estos
límites y ahora es como si se hubiera
empezado a hacer de día y ya no
dependemos de esa única bombilla para
entender pues qué investigación
científica podemos hacer ahora es
difícil aterrizar pero seguro que en
unos años vamos a ver Qué consecuencias
tiene en enfermedades como el cáncer o
en enfermedades raras y terminamos solo
con esta cifra Y es que estos 40
millones de dólares es lo que ha costado
la investigación científica durante
cinco años de este consorcio que ha
desarrollado la investigación y nos
recuerda Pues que al final estos avances
que tendrán resultados palpables en los
próximos años son los frutos de la
inversión económica de la colaboración
entre disciplinas y entre ciencias y
también del tiempo no y ojalá lo puedan
seguir haciendo porque el objetivo es
que A mediados del año que viene esta
secuencia aumente a 350 personas por lo
tanto todavía ampliemos más este Rango
de luz Muchas gracias por ilustrarnos
sobre este tema que puede llegar a ser
bastante complejo nos vemos entonces en
una próxima ocasión Gracias Andrés